I'm gonna get started because we have a
lot to cover today so the goal with this
talk is we're talk about probability in
statistics who has any kind of
background in probability and statistics
that's how the curiosity great one class
counts yeah definitely
and this would probably be a different
view of probability in statistics and
you've seen before and my goal is trying
to be pretty ambitious so I'm trying to
cover like basically everything in 90
minutes so obviously that's a lot and
the real intention is to give you sort
of from nothing to the generalized
linear model which is something we use
all time in statistics this talk
obviously is going to have to move
pretty quickly because of that but every
other session on this track today
coincidentally sort of overlaps with the
things here so if you're interested in
any one of the things I talked about I
know there's an a/b testing talk after
this there's one on parameter estimation
after that and then there's another one
on using stand for linear models will be
using PI mc3 today but you'll see that's
all there so I'll give you a few seconds
sort of get notebooks and everything
ready yeah yeah there is a requirement
is actually on the on here there is a
bit of instructions if you want to
install that so this is Python 3 I it
would require Python 3 for this but
there's a requirement text should
hopefully install it correctly but it
should be Python 3 if it's not specified
in there you're probably right I
probably should have specified a Python
3 yes yeah yeah yeah and hopefully yeah
I think you're right I think I did not
all right so yesterday's talk we're
gonna go through this series of
notebooks split into three parts the
first part is gonna talk so we're gonna
start from zero that you don't know
anything about probability at all
we're gonna talk about probability and
then from there we're gonna get to what
statistics is and then we're gonna talk
a little bit about what's very important
called parameter estimation and
hypothesis testing and then we'll
introduce the generalized linear model
which is the workhorse of probability
and statistics so and after that you
kind of get a sense of how to actually
apply stats to regular sort of everyday
problems that you will come across and
yeah okay so let's start so I'm gonna
start with this simple class right here
and one thing I want to point out
there's no point the first the only
thing we're really important here is
time so there's no importing NP random
or random or any of these libraries
we're just gonna start with everything
sort of transparent the only thing
that's gonna make this mysterious is
time so we have this very very simple
magic coin class and we're gonna see why
this coin is so Magic soon I hope and so
you can see it's very simple it just
takes when you know do not leave the
podium it just takes a very it's a very
simple thing it takes an initial it
takes an end a value to initialize the
coin with and then you can flip the coin
I call good statistical coins and when
you flip the coin it just takes time the
current time as an integer and modulo
ends that and if that's zero that's the
result you get right so just to walk
through what's happening there if we get
our current time I see it's you know
with time in seconds from some arbitrary
date in 1970 related to UNIX I believe
and we turned into an int we get an int
here and then if if our n is 2 and we
modulo that by C well this is so this is
actually a great example so this number
is not the same right so this modulus 2
would be 0 but clearly at the time when
I ran this notebook if I run it again
it's gonna be today so there's a little
different every time because we don't
see what time is so we're gonna create
this magic coin and we're going to flip
it but don't look at the result yet okay
so this magic coin is very easy to
understand if it actually is anyone have
any questions so this is is there any
questions about how this coin is set up
because it's not that shouldn't be too
complicated but you should definitely
have this coin should be completely
transparent and non-magical at this
point so when we flip this coin we get a
result and this is where probability
comes in we know exactly how this coin
works the only thing we don't know is
what time it was when we called flip
right there's some sort of state there
in the world that we missed out on and
this is where we need to know
probability we start thinking about how
probability works so the coin can only
be one of two values it can either be
true or false and it can't be anything
else but if I said what is the value of
coin once your beliefs about the value
of coin true and false is not really a
great set of tools yeah it's fine
overnight that it's not really a great
set of tools to work with to describe
this problem right we don't we don't
know but we know something or actually
we know nothing in a way right so we
know we know that we it's either one of
those two things and we really don't
know which of those two things it is so
we can think of probability as this if
we map true to one and false to zero we
can sort of think about probability as a
softer kind of truth value system right
so we don't know the value this coin is
a good guess for the value of this
result that we have is 0.5 right if true
is 1 and false is 0.5 is right in the
middle and that's literally all we know
about this coin is that we know
basically nothing it could be either one
of those things so this is important I
want to sort of impress on you when you
think about 0.5 you think well Python
doesn't have a point 5 type a value
that's not like a boolean thing this is
a boolean type it can either be true or
it can be false but it can't be 0.5 and
this is actually a really really
important thing about how probability in
statistics work we make statements about
probability we're talking about
probabilities in our mind okay
so it's true that the result has not a
point 5 value 0.5 expresses what we know
about the state of that result in that
coin and so we have this clear picture
of the world and how things work we know
exactly how the magic coin works there's
no randomness out there
randomness is just because we're
ignorant about the current time and so I
always think if we think this way it
kind of makes a lot of probability
problems clear so nasim to life has this
famous book called fooled by randomness
right and when we think about fooled by
randomness we think about this
randomness that's like out there in the
world this sort
chaotic force but when we think about
random this is a statement about our
minds this title seems much less
shocking right so if we write this to
say fooled by the ignorance of the full
nature of the process is influencing my
naive life this seems quite obvious
right when you think about that way go
yeah of course another example I always
like thinking about is you know
Einstein's favorite quote about
Heisenberg uncertainty right he says God
does not roll dice right and that's what
you think like yeah the universe can't
be random it can't just be chance but
when you think about that as a statement
about knowledge Heisenberg sort of says
well there's a limit to how much we can
know about the universe right so you
could rephrase God doesn't throw dice to
saying something like you know we can
now no we can not there's a limit to the
full intentions and actions of God that
we can know which is a much more kind of
obvious statement
so in general when you're doing
probability statistics and actually the
deeper you get into it the harder this
temptation is to sort of think of
randomness out there we think of like
normally distributed random variables of
all these things and we think about that
as being probability out there but
probability is always in here and in
general when you keep that in mind you
make much less statistical errors when
you're trying to solve problems okay so
now that we have is loads we can look at
the result and every time you run this
it's a little different which is kind of
cool
so this is false and if you all have the
notebook up you can run it and obviously
some of you will get true some of you
get false and now probability is gone we
know exactly what happened we know the
time was even when we called flip and we
have this result in our hand so that's
sort of the basic idea of probability is
like a single value but the cool thing
is because we mapped probability to
boolean logic we actually now can start
thinking but can we do other logical
things so as programmers we're very
familiar with boolean logic to solve all
types of problems we've got naught and
in or are like foundational tools that
we use as programmers right we can use
these same tools as probable lists so in
logic we have not and not as this sort
of simple negation and this is we all
know this but let's walk through it not
true is false not false is true if we
want to make this probabilistically we
just say so not in probability it's just
1 minus whatever the probability of our
thing is and this works perfectly fine
for the case where we mapped probability
to directly the truth right if we just
want to replace boolean sin
with probabilities it still works just
fine right so one minus one is zero
which is false that's what we want
one minus zero is one which is true
which is also what we want but now we
get this extra flexibility here we can
say things like 1 minus 0.25 and now we
have a negation so we have this more
powerful negation it's a bit more
flexible that we can use for other
things we also get ant so we have true
and false
we know this false they both have to be
true right true and true is true and
false and false is false we have a
probabilistic ant and one thing I should
note is these are theirs if we get in
something called conditional probability
which we're not going to talk about
today these definitions just get a
little extra extension to them so this
is the case when two things don't depend
on each other one information about one
doesn't change just know that you may
see variations on this that are a bit
more complex but don't worry about that
for this point so one this is interim
probability we make and is does
multiplication so we can combine two
probabilities that we will see if they
both happened using and which is
multiplication so again this works
exactly the same as truth a regular
truth tables right so true and true is
true true and false is false false if
false is false but again we get this
great extension where we can tell you
I'm not sure and I'm not sure so 0.5 and
0.5 and I get 0.25 so I get this way to
combine my uncertainties in a logical
way and the last logical tool we have is
or right so of course you can derive XOR
and all these things if you wanted to
but or it's a little bit more
complicated because of the math me
audience or are we know in logic right
or is true or false is true true or true
is true obviously true or false is true
and false or false is false so as long
as one thing is true
it's true now in probability this
actually a mistake that's common we will
make this so they think okay we did
multiplication for and if we just do or
we can add them all up right the
probability of rolling a 6 or a 5 or a 3
on a dice you just keep adding this up
but what happens in practice and we
don't have time this ought to go into it
is you'll end up actually over counting
if things can't both happen like
flipping a coin heads rolling a 6 so we
need to account for that so we have this
little extra term here so there's a
probability of event a high probability
plus the probability event B minus the
combined
probability of both of those events you
don't have to know it deeply why at this
point but just know this is the actual
rule for or and again if we just
replaced boolean and Python with
probabilities and replaced or with this
we would work out and so we see 1+1
works out because it's 1 plus 1 upon
post yeah 1 plus 1 minus the probability
of 1 plus 1 and 1 times 1 right so
that's going to be 1 which is great as
we want it to be and you notice if we
didn't have that term that multiplies
and takes that away we'd be over
counting we get 2 and probabilities are
between 0 & 1 this is a rule that we
have so that would not be good so this
works out and we can see 1 & 0 which is
the same is true or false we get what we
want we get true and of course we get 0
if they're both false and then again we
get this extension where we can really
ask more complicated things what's the
probability of an event that we're point
two-five short of happening and or an
event that's point 3 we can do the math
and we can get it out and we get an
answer for that ok so these are the
basic rules we can have it so now we
have this whole framework for dealing
with uncertainty all right perfectly on
time which is great so we have this
thing we have this random result and now
we can start thinking about how we can
combine all this things we don't know
and this is actually very powerful tools
this you can take this and if there's a
lecture stop now you can sort of work it
out on your own and solve a ton of
problems and we're gonna see an example
of that next so we're gonna make another
magic coin so yeah so logic this is
these are two points I want to drive
home to as well as logic is how we
reason about facts things that we know
for sure and things that we don't know
for sure we use probabilities and
obviously in the real world almost
everything we don't know for sure
there's always some little margin of
uncertainty you're not basically
anything so we're gonna create an poin
and end for this coin is going to be 3
right so that means if the time when I
flip this coin is divisible by evenly
divisible by 3 we're gonna get true
right the last time it was easily evenly
divisible by 2 it was true so it is even
so every third number is gonna be that
so we want to come with the probability
for this sort of intuitively and this is
the correct answer as well the intuitive
probability for this is that okay so if
I just pick some numbers one out of
every three is gonna meet my condition
so I'm gonna say it's a one-third
probability that I believe it's true
okay is everyone following so far good
so again this is we can go into deep
philosophical discussion of how we prove
that this is true but in this case your
intuition is right
one out of three events is the one we
care about that's gonna be true okay so
now we're going to do something a little
bit more complicated here we're gonna
create this results list okay and we're
gonna we're gonna create this and then
we're gonna append this new magic coin
to it it's gonna flip it one thing it
interesting is because it's using time
if you put these all on a single cell
and run them at the same time they'll
all be the same because it all happens
at the exact same time right I was in a
second it was far as pythonic Harris so
when I first built this out I was like
huh why is it always true we're always
false I'm like oh yeah cuz they all
executed under a second it actually is a
good point about only think about the
more we know about how something works
the more we can reason about what we
don't know right so you know if they're
all on the same cell they're gonna be
the same so if wait a few seconds and if
we run this one and now we have another
probability question okay so this is a
bit more complicated before I just want
to know whether or not the result was
true now I want to know what this Python
statement is going to evaluate to and so
we've added two things to a list and we
flipped them at time so I don't know
what times they were and now we have two
results and I want to know the results
that is any right so we're gonna walk
through how we're gonna reason about
this but just for to think about how
much of is this is minorly more
complicated case but it's gotten a lot
trickier to sort of reason about how
confident we are and that so the
probability of true is one-third we put
two quote we flip the coin twice put
them in there and if any of them are
true then we're set but we have to sort
of think how this works so we can think
about all the possible things that could
happen in general if you're not sure
where to start the probability counting
out the outcomes you want looking at the
outcomes you care about is a good way to
come up with your probability so again
we can prove that and all kinds of fancy
ways but this is a generally good rule
and it's tricky when you can't count
outcomes like probability of whether
tomorrow being rainy those are a little
bit more sophisticated ways to think
about it but for this we can just list
out all the possible outcomes so these
are the things that could have happened
right we could have true and true false
or false false or true true or false
there's four outcomes and we just need
to know the probability of the ones that
we actually care about which is true
true false true and true false so
we can actually use our logic of looking
at this so we know that the probability
of true and true right so here's a
numerate through all these look at the
probabilities and we can just use our
basic logic right so we want to know the
probability of true and true right so
that's a Sailaja chol statement we can
use our rules there so the probability
of true and true is one over nine right
because we went through those rules
before it's one-third times one-third
now we have one over nine that's how
sure we are that that outcome happened
then we have the next outcome we care
about which is false so we can actually
go through all of these so we know the
probability of false is just the
opposite of true and we can use the
logic for this to figure out that the
probability of this one is four over
nine okay again this is okay if the math
is like boring you over it like 9:30 the
morning it's totally fine you just have
to remember that this is the we're just
doing the and and ORS and nots that we
just went through the basic logic there
so there's really no like the equations
can make your mind feel very tired but
this is really just the application of
that basic sort of logic we had and then
we have these other two outcomes that we
want which is the true and false and
it's in this flip is gonna be the same
right so this is true and false in this
case we get two ninths and so we can put
the things with things without comes we
care about our true true true false or
false true right so those are the three
there's the three outcomes that we
actually care about and we just don't
know if any one of them happens so one
or the other or the other and since they
can't all happen at the same time we
don't actually to worry about over
counting so we can add them up and we
get four over nine okay so one way to
look at this is okay to each of the
outcomes we care about and we're just
gonna or all of them and see what we get
and we get five over nine another way we
could solve this is you can say wait we
know the probability of false and false
is four over nine all I care about is if
it's not false over false so that's
going to be one minus four over nine and
it works the endpoint I'm showing here
is that this is consistent right you can
express the or of all the possible
outcomes so we care about or the
negation of the outcome we don't care
about and both of those should be
logically consistent and they are so
even though there's a lot of sort of
calculation happening here it's really
still boiling down to basic logic which
is pretty cool now we get some really
powerful out of this so let me just see
what the result is because I always like
see what happened
it happened great so so this is cool and
let's try one more thing so that was
already a lot of work and we just had
two things in our list
so here's had two things in our list and
already I can feel like everyone's
brains reckon right this is pretty good
we're gonna make a a more tricky one so
this is our third magic coin and it's
initialized with four so it's gonna be
probability of one over four and we're
gonna flip it and we're gonna flip it
again and again and again and again
alright and so wait what was the idea
here oh yeah so yeah so I want to see
what the length is all right so this is
much trickier so so the question I have
is is how long is I wanna make
statements about how many things are
true in this right so we're going
through there for each of if it's true
it's gonna return true and I want to see
how long that is right so we're
filtering so we flip this one two three
four five times and I want to know how
many times it came out true right that's
my result three so the question now is
what is that number and this gets really
hard really fast right even though we're
just dealing with these some rules of
probability these logical things is
really tricky we can't go to our old
solution where we enumerate all the
outcomes because we've got a lot of
outcomes now even though it's just five
coin tosses all right we've got five
things in this array I just want to know
how many aren't true and how probably
how likely that is how likely is it that
two are true so this is really really
tricky thankfully we have a probability
distribution for this so this we're
gonna import scipy eyes stats and we're
going to use this binomial distribution
that they have and this distribution
we're not going to derive it from
scratch but it basically we actually did
so what this distribution does is it
does this work for us we enumerates the
possible outcomes and then it counts how
many truths there could be and the
probability of each of those right so
we're gonna walk through this
distribution but the binomial
distribution is just a function you can
think of it as like a regular Python
function that you tell it the
probability of an outcome happening you
tell it how many times you flipped it
and then it will tell you for any given
input how likely that is to happen what
the probability is for you and it's
doing it the same way we calculated this
it's just that you don't have to do this
by hand anymore so we can see so we so
this was our actually should be one over
for anyway if we did all this is for
this is for the first example so in this
first example we had n is two right we
had to the previous one we had two
things each one had a probability of 1/3
of happening we can actually have it do
the math for us and we get this so this
is the same thing as the 4 over 9 that
we expected so this is the probability
of getting no true with 2 this is the
probability of just getting one and this
is a probability of getting 2 and we can
add these two together so this saves us
doing all the work we did for that first
part so if you did the first part and
thought this is really confusing I don't
really do this much kind of probability
you don't have to over again now that
you've seen how you build that up you
can use the binomial distribution to do
that work for you and it's really
important because we need to be able to
do that to solve the problem we have now
so we're just going to look at what this
looks like where we have 5 after this
the distribution for 2 so this is what
we this is actually what this is
visualizing what this distribution looks
like this is the binomial distribution
for that previous example we had 2 coin
tosses so the probability of getting
zero one and two true values in that
array now we have five tosses so this is
our problem now that's why we really
need these distributions because even at
five this problem has become really
really hard to do with pencil and paper
to sort of just think through so we need
these tools to solve this problem for us
and we're going to do this for five give
this distribution plot it out and you
can see what this looks like so this is
really useful because now if I ask you
we can actually look at it but if I said
what's the probability of getting just
one true value out of that
list that was probably the result three
is length one you can look and go it's
gonna be about point four what is it is
it likely that all five are true no it's
almost not it's not gonna happen right
is it more likely that I have zero or to
all these questions can be answered with
the distribution which is really useful
so yeah so we can see it was a
probability getting one we get that
exactly we can we can look at if we
wanted to know what the probability of
all these sort of other values right
want to know this greater than one I can
get
some of all the values greater than one
here all those things so we can sort of
start reasoning much more complex ways
about this thing which is really hard to
do the probability form because we have
this distribution ok so this is this is
the Bernoulli distribution that's going
to the end of this part but let me get
you to where we sorta start think about
difference between actually 1 another
reason was 1 so this time we got just 1
so this is this is where this is
probability and so I think a big thing
people question is the different
probability in statistics and so
probability so far we've known
everything we know how exactly how the
magic coin works we know exactly what
parameters are in it it's completely
transparent we just have one tiny pieces
of information and we don't know but we
have a very clear understanding of how
much we know and what we don't know and
so we're able to do these things and
even though it's a bit of work to do all
the probability we can still work
through it and now that we have tools
like the binomial distribution we can
ask all kinds of questions and sort of
get a better sense of this so this is a
slightly different variation on our
magical coin this magical coin is
initialized with a value that we don't
know what it is so I took the time right
and I made it in the same way the inside
logic does for this I added one to it so
this is non zero so this could be
anything between 1 & 7 is the value that
this coin was initialized with but we
don't know what that is and so now when
I do something like this I just put 3 in
here it's really hard to make a guess
what's in there because we don't know
anything about the coin and this is
where we actually need to sort of flip
our thinking around so before we're
thinking in purely probabilistic terms
we were asking questions about what data
should I expect given that I don't know
right what's the probability I get a
head or a true value right what's the
probably that I get 3 those types of
questions all right we know how the
machine works we know how the object
works we want to make it an assumption
by holliday it comes now we're gonna use
the data to start making assumptions
about how this models working and that's
what about statistics work that's why
there's the data and data science
because we need data to understand it
without any information you don't know
very much about this coin at all
it could be anywhere from if the value
is one every result out of this coin is
going to be true if the value is 1/7
it's going to be very rare to see truth
the difference between 1/7 and one-sixth
is not so big so it's gonna be hard to
see and so we can look at the results in
a second but this is this is sort of the
visual I have for for where we are now
right and we have probability we have a
very clear view of the world and we have
a very clear view of what we don't know
in this case even for this very simple
example it's not there's not a lot of
moving parts to this right anything
about the world that we try to learn
about as data scientists or programmers
there's a lot more unknowns going on in
this model there's there's not that many
moving parts but it's still very hard to
reason about you could do that and I
have homeworks at the end of these if
you want to sort of really dive deeper
after the talk but this is where we are
now right we don't even really know what
we don't know we don't even know how
we're going to necessarily tackle that
problem and part of its because the
world is sort of hidden from us and
that's the real-life problems we have
all the time right you want to know
whether a product is selling better on
your website there's a lot of
information you don't know about who is
viewing that what makes that product
successful what makes someone buy a
product then we're gonna do that in the
next section we're going to look at that
a little bit deeper so we can we can
actually look at these results I'm sure
I'm not gonna rerun this one this was an
interesting one so there's one outcome
in this magic coin where if it's one the
magic coin it's always going to produce
the value true right because anything
modulo 1 is going to be true so if we
get these results of our new magic coin
right there our new magic results where
we don't know even what it was
initialized with this gives me some
evidence that there must have been one
right the value in the coin it could
have been like two or three probably
wasn't one over seven right probably
wasn't seven was of time I ran a coin
app because if that was the case then
it'd be very very unlikely to get true
right we're not gonna do the math for
this but you can start thinking this is
how you start thinking and statistically
right given that I saw this now what do
I know about plausible explanations for
what's happening inside that coin and
that's when you think about how we do
business problems right that's what
we're always trying to get we're trying
to get a plausible explanation for
what's happening out in the world we
don't really know what the world the
real world is a much more complicated
version of the magic coin and what we're
trying to do is take the data from the
world and try to interpret and get a
sense of what's happening out there and
so when we run this again
you can see this case I'm
and you can intuitively feel this right
if you get this many true results you
can at least you I think everyone here
sort of feels like it should probably be
one because even if it was a two what's
the initial value in there right it's
really unlikely that in in five in six
coin tosses you're gonna get all heads
right you're gonna sort of feel that you
can work it out mathematically that's
what statistics is about it's actually
putting numbers to that but here we can
tell I'm pretty confident that this is a
value of one so the homework for this if
you want to do this is you can actually
just sort of explore this if you really
understand this last example here this
for a statistical example of the magic
coin then you really understand all of
statistics so this seems like a trivial
problem but if you if you sit home
tonight and you sit at home this week
and sort of start to shrink thinking
about how this coin works in trying to
unravel it you can work out the
probability from the very beginning
because you look at the probability of
each time you can you can think of what
possible outcomes those would give you
put it all together it's a very
complicated thing it's not it's not an
easy homework but if you really want to
dwell on this and sort of get an
intuition for how probability works
diving into this problem deeper will
really help you and it's hard so if you
feel like wow this is tricky this is
actually tricky and then answering
questions like okay so how many coin
tosses do I need to make a good guess
right and can I know like when it's all
true is we can make that guess pretty
quickly right we know that I'm pretty
sure that that's one inside that coin
and because it's an object in Python you
can actually peek inside right you can
see what that n is and see if you were
right but as you start answering those
questions about how you'd make inference
about that coin that is what statistics
is so that is how we think about
statistics and if you really understand
how you would run tests on that coin to
make a guess how you could differentiate
between whether it's one over whether
it's seven or six which is a really hard
case is there what possible values it
could be how you would do all that if
you can build it all out you basically
understand all of statistics in my
opinion you have them really the core
part of it and you you don't need any
more tools so what we have right here
which is pretty cool okay perfect timing
halfway through how's everyone doing
does anyone have any questions on this
first part great I really appreciate
them coming here in the morning to talk
about statistics after a conference like
that's really like I'm proud so so now
we're gonna move behind the scenes there
is gonna be some random here but you're
not gonna see it directly and and this
is gonna get into really
important idea of parameter estimation
which is what we just were sort of
talking about here you'll notice I have
a couple of classes that I developed I'm
not gonna show you how they work
because it's part of reality and real
statistics if you want when you look in
the repo you can actually look how these
these classes are written and sort of
see how they actually work they're not
that complicated they're not much more
complicated too magical but we have a
customer a product we run an experiment
so the the product class has it has a
quality number between while it's not in
force but it's between one and five and
the examples and it has a cost those are
the two basic things right so it's a
very simple product and when a customer
interacts with the product they can
choose to buy it or not and they also
the customer has internal preferences
for these things and if the and is
totally deterministic so the customer
it's only that's one way I can tell you
when the customer buys a product in this
example it's not random it's completely
deterministic if you know the internal
state of the customer you can absolutely
decide whether or not they will purchase
the product it's not this randomness out
there all the madness again is inside
our heads because we don't know how this
all works so here's the toothbrush it's
an all right toothbrush cost $4.99 and
its quality is 3.9 now I get it in the
real world this is interesting in a real
world if you have a product you don't
actually get to input what the quality
is right that would be awesome if you
could if you could build a product in
like we're only gonna build perfect claw
products that would be great in this
example we have that you do have control
over the price in real life right so
this is where like you even get when you
start using it more and more statistics
don't asking questions about like what
do I even have control over how can I
make this toothbrush do better but in
this case in this happy world we can
choose the quality of our expression
it's alright toothbrushes all right it's
not too expensive and what we can do is
we can take this and we can get a random
customer and again a customer will
deterministically buy this product
they're generated random so this
customer represents if you have a
website or I mean anyone that's doing
anything with people this represents
someone that walks in from the street or
comes to your website randomly you don't
know everything about them right there's
a lot of details about that person and
we're completely ignorant of what those
are when they get there but they are
sampled from a population of people and
they come but this is an actual instance
this person object is an instance of a
person and their preferences are fixed
once they're created and there's nothing
that we don't know what they are but
they are set
and we just decide whether they'll
purchase a toothbrush or not this person
did not decide to purchase a toothbrush
so this this is great
right and we don't really know anything
about toothbrushes the funny thing is
about this so is so we revealed an
experiment to do this but everything
with this toothbrush is it's actually
much more complicated than the magic
coin but one of the great sort of
mercies of statistics is that the more
complicated things are the sort of
broader assumptions we could make right
so we're going to just sort of think
about this as there's gonna be some kind
of rate that people buy toothbrushes
right there's some kind of probability
that if we show a toothbrush to a
customer they will buy it and this isn't
thing we do all the time in real life
right I mean I I work at Wayfair and a
huge part of my life is figuring out
what's the probability that a product
will sell if I show it to a bunch of
people and why so this is and so we're
gonna think about that's a very
simplifying statistical assumption right
that's the real the reality is this
toothbrush has these thresholds this
customer has these thresholds when they
match the customer purchases it
we're not modeling that that's a lot
more complexity we're just gonna make
the simplifying assumption that it all
kind of works out in the end
and there's a rate that if we show this
we will sell it so we're gonna design an
experiment there's an experiment class
and what this is gonna do is it's gonna
show it to a bunch of customers so we're
gonna run a test we're gonna get show it
to 20 people and we're gonna try to
figure out what is the rate that this
coin cells and then we're in statistics
land now we're gonna use probability but
the first talk is really the only part
that we're strictly in probability space
so if this part and here on out we're
trying to look into this object and try
to understand how it behaves and in this
case there is no magic end that we can
actually peek at and tell us how it
works so so we get twenty purchases we
can see some people did some people did
not even looking at this you can kind of
make some intuitive feelings for how
well this toothbrush does or does not
sell so and again this is not like the
magic coin this is it completely this is
a black box right people talk a lot
about black boxes and machine learning
and I think one thing I also like people
think but is the reality is actually the
black box it's not neural networks right
the real world is the thing that we
don't really understand and we're trying
to take a stab at it and this is sort of
an example what we're trying to do so we
showed this to all these people and we
can see in this case that
sold out of 20 so in obvious first that
if you saw this data you'd say okay
thirty percent of people will buy this
buy this toothbrush right and that's a
pretty good we call that in statistics a
point estimate it's a pretty good
estimate but given what we've seen are
there other options right is there other
possibilities and so of course right I
mean we our best guess right now is
point our intuitive guess is that it's a
thirty percent chance to sell but we
could is what if we changed our estimate
by adding 0.05 to it or subtracting
point on five for those possible of
course they're possible right but how do
we quantify that we need some sort of
way we can say how possible they are so
we think back to the binomial
distribution right we can say oh
actually so if we if we knew right if we
knew this print this estimate we have
this point three right we know how many
people we showed it to that binomial
distribution will tell us how likely
that outcome that we actually saw was if
that was true right so if the rate is
thirty percent and we go back to
probability land we assume we know we
are correct we are at 30 percent how
likely is what we saw to have happened
and we can now get a number for that
this number in a vacuum isn't super
useful
all right business tells us which of the
possible is what we can do is we can use
this as a tool to compare other guesses
right so if I were to subtract from my
estimate point zero five we can do the
same thing and you can see it's less
likely right if that was the true rate
if less than if point zero five less
than what we observed what we our guess
is was the true rate then it's going to
be slightly less likely but certainly
not impossible right
it's a 20% chance was our best estimate
but these other estimates that we have
we can add two as well right so of these
estimates we can see that adding point
zero five to our estimate is a little
bit more likely to have produced the
data we saw than if we subtracted point
zero five both these are fine though so
which one is it
right we don't really know and so this
gets to that sort of modeling our
internal state of what we believe so we
have three options here I know my best
option but I don't want to be
constrained to just one possible option
so we could think about this if we if we
if we did this idea right it just okay
let's let's look at the binomial
distribution let's iterate through a
bunch of possible outcomes right so in
this case we're just going by every
Oh point 10 guests right like what if it
was 20% what if it was 50% we get a
distribution that looks like this right
so our 30 our 30% is that peak right
there that's our best guess but you can
see how well every other guess we could
have made described it so it's really
really not possible looking at this and
it's 80% right if I said I think this
brush is great I don't think it's this
an OK toothbrush I think this is amazing
toothbrush and people love it and they
really are gonna buy it at 80% and we
just got really unlucky you would go I
don't think that's true well it's really
unlikely that this this toothbrush is
that good and we happen to get with 20
people this outcome and you say yeah but
we'll there's all kinds all the guesses
we could make here right and so we can
do that so we can we can keep making
this more and more fine-grained all
right we get a smoother and smoother
curve and we gets beautiful and you're
doing math when you get these really
beautiful smooth curves that's real life
never looks like that so now you know
you've must have done something smart
because you got a smooth curve so this
is where we want to be and this
introduces the other distributional use
today which is called the beta
distribution we're definitely not kind
of derive how to get there but this is
the intuition behind the beta
distribution the beta distribution is a
very fancy sounding one it has two
parameters it's a little confusing so it
has two parameters which is alpha and
beta and alpha is how many successes you
had so how many true values how many
sold beta is how many you didn't which
means the total is alpha plus beta so
the binomial model right we had how many
successes you had and how many total
when we do the beta we always look at
successes versus failures and we have to
add them together to get the toll this
distribution is a continuous
distribution which for all is practical
for this talk this means that it goes
over every possible rate that we could
have and it also is scaled a bit
differently so that when we do math on
it it all sums up to one to get a
complete probability but this is
basically what it looks like and this is
really useful because this now remember
that sort of fuzzy image of our brain we
didn't know statistics for this
toothbrush problem this is now the
clearer image of our mental state this
is what we actually believe and when you
saw this toothbrushes you don't
necessarily feel that right when you
just see okay I see I see six hold out
of twenty I don't know what I believe
this is the correct
and it's some tweaks we can do on this
I'd only be too dogmatic but this is
sort of the correct model of your mind
which is a really useful tool to have
because now you can start doing
quantitative things so this lets us do
oh this is my favorite part of this
actually so normally when you get
introduced to this you have to do
calculus to solve this and everyone's
like hey I'm out I don't need I don't
want to calculus but because we're all
Python programmers here the best thing
is we can just sample from this okay so
this is we're going to use and we're
gonna use numpy the random beta this
will sample from this distribution that
we have here and say okay so what we do
with that the cool thing is we can just
ask questions about samples and they'll
give us the answers we want which is
really really good and it's not even a
hack it's the way you have to do it when
you get to really hard problems so you
don't have to feel shame for not doing
math you can actually feel like you're a
sophisticated person doing a Monte Carlo
simulation because you are and if some
math person tells you all you can't do
this by hand you can say no you don't
because once you start getting into real
problems which you'll have a couple of
speakers so they talk about when you
need to really complicated things you
need to use PI MC or Stan they are doing
a very very very sophisticated version
of this but the end of the day we can
only solve your only hard problem so
this is the way to start thinking start
thinking in terms of samples it's not a
cheap trick it's actually the way we do
it professionally and the cool thing is
now you can encode ask all these great
questions okay so what's the probability
that the rate is actually greater than
than point four right given that I saw
this is is it possible then it's much
better than I saw right we saw a 30
percent is it could it be 40 percent now
you can actually put a probability to
that so you just literally like ask that
question of the samples right how many
of these samples are greater than that
how many samples were there
that's our probability of that happening
that's really cool it only had solved
that by integrating over the
distribution you don't have to integrate
ever again now they have Python and then
of course the nice thing is this is sort
of first it's if we look at the samples
from this distribution I put that math
in there cuz you just got to put some
math in these talks see if you legit you
can see you can see when we estimate
this right the mean of these samples is
the same mean we came up when did this
empirically which is a sort of a good
sanity check that we take a whole bunch
of samples the average of this is
exactly what we estimated for that and
that's because that is that's what the
math says that the expectation the beta
distribution
is alpha over alpha plus beta which
again alpha plus beta is a total so just
how many you saw over how many there are
it's like a really fancy mathematical
way to say that so if you like are just
averaging over what you saw you can show
with people that and like wow very
sophisticated okay so now everyone's
favorite thing hypothesis test this
actually what got me into Bayesian stats
because I hate T tests and I hate
p-values and nobody understands them and
people who tell you they understand them
are gonna have someone else that tells
them that they don't understand them
because they're silly and we're not
gonna have any p-values in this okay so
the cool thing is we already have this
great framework for hypothesis testing
so we're going to just a new toothbrush
the luxury toothbrush this is a great
great toothbrush but it cost more right
again it's nice to be able to control
that quality so the luxury toothbrush is
another toothbrush and it cost more it's
better the the thing is you know how is
this gonna perform when we try to sell
it the cool thing is my rotors code I
actually had no idea how this is gonna
work like so even I did not know this is
the answer that's why I actually didn't
sample from distributions for this I
have this actual rule behavior in these
models they're really deterministic
we're deciding things so even I didn't
actually know how this was gonna work I
wasn't like I murdered a sample from a
normal and I know the answer I don't
know the answer I'm gonna do now cuz I
did this talk so our experiment class
has this nice ability to take two
products in and it will run an a/b test
which just means we're going to show
when we run experiments now rather than
showing one product we're gonna show the
two products the two groups of people
and get results from both there are two
separate groups of people but we just
assume that they're there you know
randomly distributed from the same group
of customers just random people come in
to the website we show them different
toothbrushes to see how many buy them so
we're gonna do a test with 30 these are
actually kind of fun I'm afraid to blow
your honor but yeah so this is house for
30 we're gonna show it to 30 customers
and we can see you know we know how it
so a the the a purchases the first
argument there is the product a and the
second argument is a product B it's an
a/b test there's gonna be another talk
today on a be testing in depth so if you
like this you can go to that and get
sort of a much deeper dive into this but
here we go we got all these values for
this and we get the logger toothbrush
looks like it's old a little worse
we can print this out okay so we do we
do see this and this is where parameter
estimation comes in because you might
see that and go on why do I care about
how certainly about to crush telling ifs
thirty percent time is fine but this is
where it really becomes important
because now we have these two estimates
and we want to know how likely is it
that I'm wrong right so if I look at
this I say okay the the cheaper
toothbrush sells a lot better people
don't care about quality as much as I do
price they're much more price sensitive
and they are quality sensitive all I
care about is is I look at this this is
I'm done but that's why we need stitches
you could be wrong if I do this is two
toothbrushes you wouldn't believe me
right we only saw 30 when we came to
thirty customers do we have enough
information to know are they different
enough that we can so what we can do is
we can is this a long enough stuff for
prodding for running this parrot we can
plot this out so we can plot these two
beta distributions right so each of this
estimates from the data we got for each
of the toothbrushes so we have the log
three toothbrushes beta distribution
there and the regular toothbrushes over
there and you can see there's a lot of
overlap right so these are how we
believe about each of these but we can
see our beliefs kind of cross over a bit
and it's not quite we're not quite
certain that all cases of the larger
toothbrush being worse are true right we
have a couple we could it could be
possible based on what we've seen that
the luxury toothbrush really sells at
20%
all right and the regular toothbrush
does at ten those are both pretty
reasonable beliefs there's a lot more
obviously than the other one but we and
again we can solve this we don't have to
do any fancy math we can run it we can
run large larger tests as we and this is
a cool thing so if we run this larger I
mean actually we get better estimates
right so this is a classic like why is
data important right as we as we add
data to this these estimates get more
and more narrow so we and this time we
listed 100 people and we can see
compared to this first one this one
we're kind of confused at 30 people if
there's a lot of overlap between these
two and a hundred it starts to separate
out quite a bit there's still that
little tiny area but kind of want to be
nervous about that but again we can do
the same thing with samples right so
this is a really tricky problem we have
to sort of look at two random variables
the difference is that now we don't have
to do that we can just sample and we can
ask questions of the samples and so we
can literally say okay we get thousands
of 10,000 samples of each of these
distributions that we have and what's
the probability that let me just
again yeah so this case for this one
it's it's very unlikely right so because
they're quite separated but we want to
put a number on how separated they are
you can't really tell so what is the
real probability that the luxury is in
fact better or the or in this case I'm
gonna look at the probability of you can
look at the code right so you know I
want another probability that the
regular one is better than the lottery
one so you can literally just code that
in it take samples near distributions
and then we get an answer and so if
someone says to you okay we ran this
test with 100 people are you sure that
the the regular toothbrush tells more
you can say yeah I'm very sure I'm 99.5%
sure that that toothbrush sells better
and you can really be confident and you
built this whole thing up from scratch
so there's no magical p-value again I
put it in into t-test and it gave me
some p-value and I know what it means
and I hope I did it right you can reason
through all this we built all of this up
from basic logic we had to throw in a
little extra math for the beta
distribution but now that we have that
we're here and so you can really feel
confident about this and again you can
keep sampling and ask kinds of questions
if you want to know okay but what about
this was that you can you can tweak this
a lot and play with it and you can build
any experiment you want now so the
homework for this section is to sort of
- I haven't posts on this that goes into
a bit more detail there's ways that you
can add prior probabilities to this
which is really interesting I'm not
gonna go over that today the blog post
there does go into it quite a bit it's
actually very easy to add a sort of
prior beliefs like you might you might
be an expert in toothbrushes and say
will I know that these luxury
toothbrushes are gonna sell I don't
think that hundred is right I think that
this toothbrush has got supremely
unlucky that's a toothbrush expert I
recommend you take my advice you can
actually incorporate that into the
estimate which is very cool let's see
where we're at
oh great we actually have a little bit
of time that went faster than I expected
I'm wonderful does anyone have any
questions about this part so far no
questions great so we're gonna actually
succeed at this custody part three works
oh this is great okay so this is the
next level up so I had this beer the
other day was really good I don't know
it just about so the generalized linear
models like a robot I don't
so if you've done enough statistics or
talked to enough statisticians you hear
about linear models all the time if
you're like in a neural network person
people like me are always saying have
you tried logistic regression and you
get really annoyed and you know why does
people talk about linear models the
whole time is so annoying they don't
they know that we have nonlinear models
that are very powerful so if you have a
machine learning background how do you
do a lot of machine learning or any
machine learning okay yeah any made a
lot okay great so you're probably
thinking I know logistic regression I
know any regression will it's a toy
model you use it to show these things
work that we can get random force and
then we just build Ganz and it's great
this is a very different view of how
linear models work and we're gonna we're
gonna think about them quite differently
and we're gonna focus on different
things about them in protection we don't
care about the predictions which I could
write there's not gonna be any
cross-validation in this section and
you're gonna the cool thing is though
once you see what you can use linear
models for you like that it's basically
all of Statistics I feel really cheated
that they made it sound so hard this is
where you will know it also so yeah
we're getting into linear models right
away I believe so we're gonna import a
whole bunch of stuff okay so in case
you're not familiar with the linear
model everyone who did high school math
should know this should this like should
bring back like terror of like I know I
think of algebra oh my god who ever met
like rise over run intercept that's the
linear model right meteorologists says
like we've got some slope M we have an X
which is some value we care about we
have some intercept B and that's a
linear model right everything's a
straight line great so we're actually
not gonna use a dot linear model or like
this example so I have a long post on
this really is logistics aggression
which is an extension so when I talk
about you may have heard of the
generalized linear model before and you
know what is that all about it turns out
that first of all the linear model is
really useful and we'll see that a
second it's useful in a lot of places
and then you can do a lot more magical
stuff with the linear model by
generalizing it and what that kind of
means you just bend its space so this is
if you've used a sigmoid before logistic
regression you've seen that s right and
like someone probably put a bunch of
like complicated equations and said this
is an S so he forced these variable that
all that's doing is the exact same paper
I drew that one
it's bending the surface that that we're
looking at so underneath you see it's
the same linear model it's just warping
that surface so that's what we're just
regression it dad's the generalized
linear model does it looks at a bunch of
different ways we can use a mathematical
function to warp the surface that the
linear model lies on so it behaves in a
very nonlinear way so when you see that
s you know and it's often to sit always
sort of squishes values or values to 0 1
that's not really true you can actually
in the post I have link there you can
derive it from base theorem and sort of
see where it's coming at and understand
exactly where this warping comes from
but another way to think about it for
this example for today's talk is when
one deals probabilities not numbers that
go between negative infinity and
infinity on a straight line so we're
gonna warp the space using a function
we're not gonna go into that function
but that's what's happening so we're
gonna talk about things as if they're on
a straight line but a straight line is
gonna be that one that I've bent right
there and we're gonna use that to do all
kinds of analysis this is just so the
linear model works as probability so
this is logistic regression and in our
case that just lets us do linear models
with probabilities which is great ok so
we can now think of our problem a bit
differently and this is a pretty cool
thing but this takes a little bit of
like cognitive leap so I'm using like
the high school math notation usually
use betas because it makes you seem
really sophisticated like then we have
the beta distribution it's very
confusing so you'll see all kinds of
variations on how to write this don't be
intimidated by them if people put it in
a format used for matrices it looks
almost exactly the same so it you know
we can assume that these are whatever
this is the high school math version so
we're just trying to predict and again
we're in this bent space so these are
going to be probabilities but this is
how we should think about the problem it
makes a lot easier to decompose so we
just want to think about this ok so
someone purchased it and this is a
logistic regression problem if you don't
logistic regression you can think about
the data this way we have we have an
indicator that it is or is not luxury
right this is like the simplest data
science problem you could think of right
we have a list of someone purchased it
as rry we have a list of whether or not
it's luxury that's not that complicated
of a problem our model is gonna learn is
these two coefficients right M which is
the slope and B is the intercept and
we'll get into how to interpret those in
a second so we're gonna build our
toothbrushes up again
and we're gonna we're gonna this is a
some code to restructure them into a
data frame so they're sort of in your
typical data frame view that you sort of
have so if you've done a lot of linear
models or any kind of machine learning
work you're very familiar with sort of
like columns prediction value of a bunch
of columns okay so oh yeah so we know
the a/b test data looks like we've seen
this before
so this is going to be this is PI MC 3
I'm not going to go into the details of
Pi MC 3 all it matters is this little
guy can't step another box all that
matters is that it's the equation we
talked about is written there in that
string so purchase squiggly line this is
our I must confess I actually write a
lot are this is how you write it in R
but this literally the equation that one
just means we want to learn some
intercept and we have some variable is
luxury in our data frame that we're
going to learn and and what we're gonna
do and this is an interesting model so
one thing to think about with this I
don't think I actually wrote this down I
kind of wanted to so one thing to think
about with this is that the way this map
works out right so we're gonna learn
some intercepts some be and is luxury
well is luxury is binary right so it's
either 1 or 0 and we think about this
math it's gonna be some number times 1
or 0 okay we actually I can write this
here I'm really excited to get to use
some white for it I love white ports so
so any think about what's gonna do on
this thing right so we're gonna have
some Y which is our purchased and it's
gonna be equal to some intercept so some
coefficient ham right times the is
luxury almost call it is like I said I
want to write plus some B okay so the
question it might not be obvious here so
how are we gonna learn about the regular
toothbrush and the luxury toothbrush
from this data so whatever number this
is right and in this case negative is
bad positive is good I'll explain that
in more but this deaths in general that
number the number that comes out of this
is gonna be kinda hard to interpret
right away but this is just a 0 or a 1
ok so whatever this number is let's say
it's negative 10 right well if it's not
luxury than this 0 we don't care about
this right and then all that we're left
with the probability of predicting is
just B so this B is going to be related
to a regular toothbrush because if it's
not luxury it's like regular and if it
not luxury this thing gets canceled out
and so when it is luxury it's it's gonna
be whatever this is times 1 plus B so
this seems like it's kind of doing this
fancy thing that's really really just
switching these things on and off and so
what this is going to learn this is
luxury this model the coefficients are
on here this M is going to be how
knowing whether it's luxury changes the
outcome so that's why if this M is
negative it means knowing that this
brushes luxury changes the probability
down if it's positive it means it
changes it up so these are gonna be in
this bent space so we're gonna turn them
back to probability so they're gonna be
very large number so much larger than 0
or 1 but in general that's the logic
we're doing here then we're gonna learn
this intercept this intercept is
actually going to correspond to how well
the regular toothbrush sells it's
actually okay if this is negative it
just means that that's a low rate but
that doesn't mean anything bad in itself
if this M is negative it means that
knowing its luxury hurts your
probability that you're gonna sell so
it's a very different way to look at the
problem in the beta distribution and
initially it's gonna seem kind of
annoying and also it's not clear how
we're going to get certainty out of this
right we want to know this distribution
of our beliefs so that's why we have
Stan I'll stand PI MC 3 Stan does the
same stuff so and neither Stan talked
today it's gonna be great so ok so we
run this we run this model and this is
what this is gonna do is this is just
gonna try and learn these coefficients
okay and it's gonna learn it by sampling
you can see it's the no u-turn sampler
is the math behind this is actually
quite cool so how this works is really
interesting I definitely can't get into
se but this is really it's what what pi
MC 3 or Stan both do under the hood is
they take that simple equation and
they're gonna they're gonna learn a
district a huge complicated function
this was not huge they learn a function
that represents the space where the
answer could be and they're gonna
literally sample from it in a very
efficient way and this can handle very
complicated models but it's all just
sampling around that space and what it's
gonna do is it's gonna sample that space
to come up with its estimates for what
these coefficients could be what M and B
could be and M is gonna be called
intercept in this and I mean B is gonna
be called intercept in the results and M
is going to be called as luxury so
don't worry about this area this is sort
of a diagnostic tool because when you do
these complicated sampling things you
have to watch out for what kinds of
issues but basically these are what our
estimates look like and again these
scales are kind of tricky because we're
not in probability space we're on that
bent piece of paper still so the numbers
look a little weird we're gonna go back
don't worry we're gonna take that paper
and unbend it but you can see what we
have here is we have these distributions
and so we have this intercept where we
have all these possible values what we
believe it this is what the sampler
found and we have is laundry which is it
and you can see this is a great example
cuz look this is zero so for this one if
it's greater than zero that means
knowing its luxury has a positive effect
on the rate of sale right because the
baseline is what the regular toothbrush
sells that's what this intercept is
that's going to be the regular
toothbrush sale rate again these numbers
are in some other space
don't worry that that's negative and
we're gonna transform them in just a
second but if his luxury is positive
that means that the load of your
toothbrush actually sells better than
the regular one because knowing that
it's a larger toothbrush means you
believe it's more likely it's going to
sell so we can see a similar kind of
structuring of the problem we had before
but with this linear model so we can we
can do the same sort of sampling so this
is to get values of is log three we'll
sample that and again we can compute the
actual probabilities here this is a
different run of the experiment so don't
think about this result compared to what
we did last in the last notebook because
this is all new data here so in this
case we look at this and we can actually
compute the probability that luxury is
better this way but it's still hard to
reason about this because we're in this
what's called the log odds space it's
just a bent paper and it's kind of
annoying to like think about this so we
have a great image of this so we're
gonna do is we're gonna take this I'm
gonna use the logistic so I chose why
it's called logistic regression we can
take this base we can actually rewarm
that paper back in we can take these
distributions and put them back in to
what they look like as probabilities
which is what we just talked about for
an hour so that's what we want to see so
again walk walking through this sort of
equation we want to start with the log
odds if the ellow is four that's the
space that we're in so we're gonna get
the samples for the intercept which is
the log Oz of the regular toothbrush the
log odds of the regular of the luxury
toothbrush
are the log odds that it is log 3 plus
log on to the regular right so a little
confusing we're just taking these to
distribute we're mining these back so
now we're going to get a distribution of
what our estimate is for the luxury and
what our estimate is for the regular
does anyone have any questions on this
part no questions that's great ok so
we're here but we're still in this
annoying space but we can use this
logistic function which will turn us
back into probabilities and we get this
which is really cool
because this looks very familiar right
it looks almost like our beta
distributions we had before
and if we took in again this is another
round of the experiment so the results
are not the exact same ones we had last
time if you look at the results from the
same beta distribution so this is this
this first graph is this is our linear
models results this is what the model
estimates for what it thinks the rate of
sales for the regular is and the rate of
sales for the luxury if we were to redo
it with beta distributions this is the
distribution we get almost exactly the
same yes
yeah that's a great question I'm glad
you asked that yeah so yeah so because
in the list and this is where the linear
model formula comes in right and this is
where I think about what and it's also
important for us thing about what these
values are
so if if it's not luxury right so Islam
3 is an indicator it's a 1 or a 0
as far as represented as if it is not
luxury then this is 0 and it's gonna
cancel out this M constant right this
coefficient here right and so we get
this so this this base thing is the
model is gonna learn is gonna be
whatever is not luxury which in this
case is regular okay so it's nowhere
it's some baseline so what the model is
a kernel or model doesn't know about the
regular toothbrush at all the model is
just saying okay when it's not luxury we
know that that means it's a regular
toothbrush it's gonna say this is the
rate I'm going to try to learn for that
because when it's not luxury this is
zero and then I don't care about that M
and all the slope doesn't matter but
when when this is one all right this
variable sort of poor naming on my
behalf because this is also the
coefficient name when this variable so
this is luxury in this chart and that's
actually I think poor naming on my
behalf
this this this is luxury is really the M
not the variable so that's actually very
confusing and I apologize for that
so we're needs like room in this
variable this variable is one I mean
that it is a lot of your toothbrush this
coefficient is going to be just what it
is right and it's going to be added to
this base rate which is the rate of the
regular so what we're learning and this
is how we have to structure it refer to
the linear model to work we're learning
the difference between the two so if we
want to know how well the we could just
look at the difference I mean if you
actually want to ask how can you look at
the difference that actually would be
totally fine to this look at this and
say this is actually all I care about
and that's fine too but if I want to
estimate what the model thinks the the
larger toothbrush is I have to I have to
add what its estimate for that is to at
estimate for the regular toothbrush
oh I'm sorry that's something yeah so
actually let me immediately hired reps
in the dia that that is confusing yeah
so I kind of went over that very quickly
so I went back and took the data and we
can think of it this way
oh I'm sorry the question was if we're
only looking at the luxury toothbrush
and but we're actually looking at both
toothbrushes combined in this data set
so the data frame is gonna have like a Y
and then an X and the X is gonna be
whether is luxury and then this is gonna
be whether they bought it or not okay
sounds like good synthetic data draw
some lines there so this is this is this
has only got two pieces of information
in the model and I really should not
have named the coefficient the same
thing as the variable itself that was
very for naming on my behalf
so yeah that is a helpful but so this
actually has rather than separate the
data we put it all into one single thing
for the model to learn and that's why
it's different than we did the beta the
beta when we did the beta distribution
estimate we looked at each data set
separately and campus to separate
parameter estimates and we use those in
this case we pushed all the data
together so that this is just the
outcomes for both so it's gonna so if
there's 30 if each thing got turned into
30 we're gonna have 60 rows in this
right because we're gonna combine all of
the rows for the one that was the
regular toothbrush and the regular
toothbrushes it's going to have a 0 here
is that we don't need to have an
encoding for regular toothbrush
yeah oh so the regular toothbrush
log-odds is just this is just this be
right so let's go back to this little
thing yes I'm just getting the values
for the intercepts so it is it's the
estimates for what this is this is what
this is actually if you learn that
distribution for this
we're just taking these samples for what
it thinks this could be all right and
we're adding because we ultimately want
to get the probability of Y right this
represents the probability of Y and so
this is going to give us a distribution
this is what this is gonna give us
distribution so yeah is that yeah
exactly yeah
yes that's correct yeah yeah oh he just
said that the log odds for luxury is M
plus B mmm mmm plus B in this in this
form is the log odds that's right yeah
yeah so if we if we look at this then
yeah M because this is this is a binary
indicator thing so this is going to be
either cancel em out or not so the log
odds for long story is just M plus B
that's right that's correct
that's correct
yeah okay great
excellent anyway and definitely because
linear models are tricky I kidding
getting this in is actually like I mean
the cool thing is this is a powerful
tool because you use it for all kinds of
stuff but actually yeah these
transformations are non-trivial and and
thinking about the results of your
experiment and especially for this
problem
you're gonna go why in the world would I
not used to pay the distribution one
that was a lot simpler this is a lot
trickier just to wrap your head around I
agree it's like very sort of like okay
what's going on but the interesting
thing I want to point out now so if we
if we go back and we did this the beta
distribution why
all right the parameter estimation way
this is this is what it would look like
it's almost identical it's
mathematically also almost identical
it's always almost so anyone that's
really a rigorous math Titian in here if
I said these are our identical let's say
that's not true you can prove it the
darish lai and the logistic normal are
not the same but they're close enough
and they always will be close enough so
this is a really cool property to have
but again this seems like a mathematical
exercise to do this why in the world do
we have to this mental contortion to get
our data to fit into a linear model but
we will show you so yeah see why do I
care so we have two pencils now a very
nice pencil and a deluxe pencil you can
tell the different cuz one is got blue
and the other one has red not very
different it's part of the exercise so
and they're not very different right
this is a very nice pencil and this is
the deluxe pencil and so the deluxe
pencil is slightly worse quality a
slightly lower price based on what we've
seen so far we should kind of believe
that the deluxe pencil is probably going
to sell better right because we've seen
that people tend to be a bit more price
sensitive than they are quality
sensitive just sort of looking at this
and we wanna test this to make sure this
is so we run this pencil test a pen test
I guess for security people and then
we're gonna we gain a whole bunch of
samples here we get a whole bunch of
samples cuz the linear model really
likes a lot of samples so so we do this
and we get something is kind of annoying
so in this case let's go to make sure we
got this right
so the the very nice pencil is a the
Deluxe pencil is be the the very nice
pencil is a bit more expensive but a bit
better very bit better and the deluxe
pencil is cheaper so we've run this
experiment should be good but we get
this kind of confusing results we have
to 2500 samples and something is not
quite right here we're getting a better
estimate for the toothbrush that does
not make sense right this other pencil
the the a toothbrush pencil a pencil
costs more and it's only a bit better
and it doesn't based on what we've seen
I'm not really comfortable at this
result so something seems to be
happening here right and if we if we
wait oh yeah so we're gonna we get me
learn this in the linear model we can
repeat this is just again putting this
data into a data frame we're repeating
the last experiment over again
and we get this and yeah you know it's
not like this no maybe it's not a
certainty interesting but if we build
this on your model we run it again it's
built the same way this is right we have
is the locked pencil we have an
intercept we get this and we go geez I
mean none of that it's really over zero
so it looks like we're very certain that
the lochs pencil is worse there's
actually a good part of your statistical
thinking you should always have kind of
like a sanity check in your head of what
you think the world should look at like
and if the world doesn't look like that
in your statistical test you should ask
why never ever like look at the output
of a model and like well the model said
what the model says we're done
statistics right and then you see that
half that's what we have a you know the
reproducibility crisis right you should
always be critical statistics because
the tip takes is based on logic it
should always be a logical argument it
should convince you you should be
convinced by your analysis and and so
when you see something like this you go
ah that does not make sense something is
wrong here you should dive deeper rather
than just saying the p-value is really
low I'm done here so you could say that
here but then you'd be wrong because I
know what happened because I designed
this experiment so already notice we
actually used a when we ran this
experiment I had a messy experiment
class so that should be a clue that
something it's not quite right here so
so we ran this with this statistic that
failed us at this point and we're
certain it's it's not right so if we
look at the customers this test also
keeps track of what the customer types
were we realize that we have this like
not great it's not all just regular
customers we have these student
customers
here right so if you look at the
customers that visited a we've got some
students in there and if we look at the
customers that visited B we have some
students there as well and it's not
obvious here if they are different but
we can go ahead and count that up and
there's a lot more students in the B
group so our test was not perfect right
we we showed these pencils to people
these are relatively expensive for a
pretty mediocre pencil if I say so
myself but it's high-quality so I guess
it's good but so this isn't great now if
we just have the beta distribution we go
ha what we're gonna do we can throw out
some data maybe we could try to balance
these now it maybe just throw the whole
experiment out but this experiment is
going wrong but we have this information
we know who bought it we know whether
the students are not that purchased it
it's a pretty reasonable assumption to
say well I think students probably a
lower price threshold than than an
average consumer if a bunch of students
come into a SAS website at you runnin
and you're trying to sell expensive
software it's not shocking that you're
gonna sell less if it's got more
students but we know they're students we
have some information about this problem
this is really helpful so we can we can
go ahead and we can get this data and
we're gonna concatenate this into a data
frame so our new only raw we have an
eraser it's very weird to have
whiteboard markers at work and an eraser
I think this is good job Microsoft this
is a good job so so we're just
concatenate me something a little bit
more complicated now
okay I didn't write this on top the nice
thing is you can kind of you don't
always write these equations but I think
it does help and I have a whiteboard I'm
gonna use this so we're gonna do is
we're gonna make a new data frame where
we have we have our Y which is what I
purchased it or not we have is deluxe I
really should have named these
coefficients different but once you do
any reason why I had made this mistake
is when you do linear models enough to
kind of internalize this thinking you
like I know I care about the coefficient
I'm just gonna need to column the same
that's a coefficient and and you do that
so we have is the logs we also have e a
student is student so we're gonna have
read so we're gonna have is indicator
it's very easy exactly like the last one
indicating whether it's is the deluxe
pencil
we also now have this one that will let
us know whether it was a student so this
is actually pretty cool so now we have a
bit more information and we have the
same property because it says binary
indicator right and this is a pretty
common thing you'll see when you're
doing statistical test is sort of you
just know whether something is true or
not and it has this nice property that
the term drops out when it's zero which
is super convenient right so now we have
three things we're gonna learn well it
will stop the intercepts which is gonna
tell us something about we're gonna
learn these things we're gonna learn the
intercept from this we're going to learn
some coefficient for it is delux and
we're gonna learn some coefficient for
his student and we're gonna learn some
intercept and the intercept is gonna be
the rate of what happens when the pencil
when the pencil is the very good pencil
very nice pencil is the lochs is gonna
be the difference from when we know is
Deluxe pencil and student is going to be
the difference between oh it's a student
so we're gonna learn three things this
time and you can think of how these are
all at it right if it's not the lux and
it's not a student we just get the rate
of the of the very nice pencil when we
try to sell it if it is deluxe but it's
not student we're gonna get we add this
and this we're going to get the rate of
it being a deluxe pencil selling if its
deluxe and it is student the students
gonna tell us how much the students
impacted this and so we're gonna learn
is actually a whole bunch of stuff which
is really cool I'm just gonna run this
so you can see it so you can see here's
our here's our thing here's our equation
right and yeah actually that is why I
need in this way because I think about
it's actually it's confusing for
learning right so those are the column
names it's gonna look for in the data in
the data frame so that is very helpful
to have the column names be the
coefficients but they're really that but
it's the X is the data frame column and
the coefficient is separate thing so
that's interesting I never thought about
that so we're gonna run this and we're
gonna get these which is really really
cool
so the inners have really don't care
about it just tells us what the rate is
our estimate for that rate and is deluxe
is now all positive right so we're not
gonna convert these back into I don't
believe I do yeah we're not gonna
convert these back to the log
probability I don't have to for this one
but we can see that we
Deluxe is all positive it being the
deluxe toothbrush as we suspected is
entirely a positive impact on a sale and
the students we have this sort of broad
at distribution there but now we have
this estimate that students is all a
negative interaction which makes sense
so now we've been able to take this
linear model which extends what we did
with the you know it's very when we
decided to replace two parameter
estimates it was annoying to use a
linear model didn't make any sense but
now this little complexity in our
experiment design we can now resolve it
and we the cool thing is we actually
learned not only do we uncover that the
deluxe crease brush probably is better
right now that we've been able to
account for their student population we
also now have information about how well
do students purchase pencils right this
is this is this assumes someone catching
this right as it assumes that the
student purchasing behavior is
independent of the of the actual pencil
itself right they just have some sort of
fixed rate that they hurt sales but out
of this now we had a test that looks
like it was a flawed test that we had to
throw out but now we actually got all
this information about how students
behave as well so we have estimates for
we know the deluxe pencil is a bit
better because as we expected it's a bit
cheaper and it should be better and also
that students are worse so we could we
could go ahead and throw these into wiki
transforming them logistic and do the
beta distribution on these and see that
a so this is the very very beginning of
we can generalize on your model but it's
a question yeah no it's a great question
I mean I think you're right yeah it is
it is it is it is drawing yeah you're
absolutely right you are learning this
much more complex thing right yeah
because we can think of this as uh you
don't have we can think this is a vector
right if you like a machine learning we
would put this as one big X and we'd
have these coefficients and we separate
them out so it's easier to read but yeah
we are getting this sort of
multi-dimensional situation and if
you're if you're asking does it get
complicated there yes it does like you
can definitely get already it's kind of
it is tricky to sort of figure out
what's actually happening right
luli in here we're basically going from
two-dimensional space to some 3d
possibly and yeah what's still well what
still is a linear what's nice as it
still just gives us the rate right so
the the ultimate thing is what we're
getting is so when I put that why there
we're really learning the probability of
of that purchase right that's ultimately
we're learning the log odds of the
probability so when we remember that way
just solve the equation or whatever
information we have we can sir that
gives us as the log odds or a
transformed version of the probability
of Y we can draw more we can throw them
on the whiteboard let me yeah this is
this is really this is really tricky and
we actually are this is we're done and
we still have 10 minutes so yeah I
wouldn't actually we're actually you can
so let me just write this out and then
did you have a question real quick is it
oh this is this formula right here this
ten Duyck oh yeah so this is this is
like shorthand for this oh yeah this is
it so in the data frame here in this
pencil test data there is a column
called this deluxe there's a column
called purchased and there's a column
called is student and the one just means
I care about the intercept you actually
I do not believe need to put the 1 there
it will always add an intercept but the
one is just notationally there so is
that is that correct I see you sticking
fit yeah I always put it there because I
want to make sure that it's there
so this means that we're gonna we have
an intercept right it's um it's gonna
learn some coefficient times one and
it's always gonna be one you don't have
to put it there it'll do it for you
yes exactly yeah so this is this is yeah
I always find this kid I actually found
our syntax very confusing yeah so what
that's what that is is it's and it's
tricky because it's this string right so
in the data frame there and this'll
actually as I write this out I can help
answer your question the same time so
this is a great combined thing yeah so
this is and you'll see the
this notation comes up in our line this
way really helps sort of stretch teasing
so in pencil test data we have a
purchase column is deluxe column and is
student column so what we're learning is
some I can't spell okay good I was awful
at spelling in like all of grade school
and I thought that would not be a
problem as an adult but it's like number
one coding error I've ever had is typos
and I really feel like I can't believe
that like primary school is right so so
what this is this is this actually is
confusing notation so it's gonna learn a
coefficient for each of these and just
like me it's gonna name them poorly so
I'm trying to think notation I don't
make it more sense so these are the
values that are going in okay we can
think of this as the values right so
there's a one which is gonna be just all
ones and it's gonna learn some m0 of one
so don't learn some coefficient m for
the one this squeedily just means equal
because we don't wanna use equals all
the time it's just a convention so that
squiggly this pretty looks very magic my
first of all squiggly I was like well
what's that squiggly all about yeah yeah
yeah or or you need to be fair to be
fair if we want to be really technical
right we could talk about this clearly
kind of implies that it's being sampled
from this distribution so it's not your
is right so yeah I shouldn't say that
you can ignore this squiggly equals
think yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah and so
this quickly actually does often in
notation mean it's being sampled from
some distribution so so it is you I do
want to correct that don't just
translate that as equals for weird
reasons the reason why is that you can
as you if you use more and more Stan or
PI MC 3 you'll see that squiggly and
that's really it usually means
especially notation it means that it's
coming from sort of so squiggly like
normal means it's coming from a normal
distribution it doesn't mean that it's a
fixed value so there's some distribution
of parameters here that's a lot to dive
into but for practical for thinking this
through that's what the equal sign goes
in your equation so yeah so what is
happening under the hood it's gonna
learn m 0 times 1 plus
and one x is deluxe
this is my time my dot its deluxe plus
m2 times is student so so these the
reason why it's a one is one times it's
always be one times this coefficient
which is the same thing as just having
that that's why this is gonna be the
intercept so yeah this is gonna be B
yeah yeah so it's learning these as each
coefficients and but when you think
about this B times a constant value it's
always gonna be the same right it has no
you just gonna learn some consistent
thing there so that's what that's gonna
be and then so for this and this is get
so so this is and then I have a blog
post that does go a lot more detail but
this this represents a linear version of
our probability right so this is not
actually a binary at all this is gonna
be some number that when we do the
logistic gives us the probability of
purchased give in the data we have which
is a bit more nuanced so you're actually
learning a probability of purchased
rather than a binary purchase there's
not a threshold here so you're gonna
learn these coefficients so so if in the
case where this is always gonna be one
right because there's no data being
input here when it is delux and it is a
student this is gonna learn it's gonna
multiply whatever the penalty for being
or penalty reward for being as Deluxe's
plus the penalty reward for being a
student right and you add them out
you're gonna get this and you're gonna
transform it and it's gonna give you the
probability the only reason that these
annoying transformation is because
otherwise it wouldn't be linear so we
need to have that that's a generalized
linear model part of it but basically
this is gonna be some this is gonna
represent how much this hurts or
benefits and you can keep going forever
or you can add more and more and more
things the tricky thing is it this model
this is where is the linear model and
just like it's a regular linear
regression you have a sort of weaknesses
right where you can you can see them
more easily in linear mode a traditional
linear model but the the issue is it
doesn't this model does not account for
the fact that maybe students really like
Deluxe pencil for some other reason
right
this model assumes that students buy
pencils at a lower or higher rate in
pendant of everything else about the
pencils and it's not something I have to
keep in mind especially for experiment
design so if this deluxe pencil said
like I hate students on it then this is
not really gonna be correct right if
there's some reason why students would
be like at one time it says it hates me
yeah right exactly exactly yeah this is
not a pencil I want so there are all
kinds of assumptions in here so you know
but this is this is a framework when you
think about this you can start asking
all kinds of more and more complicated
questions you could have a whole bunch
of demographic information and then
you're going to get estimates about all
the demographic information which is
which is pretty cool so and then this is
where if you're a machine learning
person like wait we don't even care
about this I don't care about the
outcome you can write if you're trying
to like come up with some some risk you
want to have right if you want to have
an if you want to be like what's the you
know we want to only we want to put
promotion on the website but only if
there's a greater than 20% chance that
the person's gonna buy the product right
you might want to do this or the
homeworks actually is so these are
discrete things right these are binary
things we we've seen that we have this
quality and this quantity right so we
could think about this problem a little
bit differently we could we could ignore
all these other things we've seen and we
could we could generate a whole bunch of
products right and we could say okay
given its quality and its price learn
some coefficients there I think that -
right and now you actually have this
model that says okay I need this to sell
twice as much the rate this is where
this is where these things get really
interesting it's get really powerful
this is when people talk about
interpretable models versus explainable
models this is an interpretable model
because if you modeled Brian let's say a
whole bunch of products here right we
just seen a toothbrush in the pencil we
know that price seems to be more
important than quality we don't know
exactly how they work but you can
actually start learning exactly how they
work so you could generate in this
example or in real life take the
products you have with a whole bunch of
different prices right and you can say
who did it sell or did it not based on
just its price and its quality and then
these will give you how those affect
things so you might say I need to you
can answer it really kind this is like
when the homework questions you can
answer questions like I need to sell 20%
more
of these I know that price has an impact
on this if you can learn exactly how
price has an impact you can learn
exactly how you have to change the price
to increase the chance that you'll sell
by 20% yeah yeah exactly yeah great
great so the syntax of that so we'd
still have so we'd have to have a data
frame that had purchased and quality
columns right and it's totally fine if
they're they're numbers so that would be
must actually I mean looks like no mess
up so yeah this the purchase that would
be if we have the data frame we passed
in it has those things it's gonna be
pushed this is my quotes purchased
squiggly tilt one you put the one
anywhere I believe one plus one oh I'm
working there anymore price whatever the
assuming that price the the data frame
column for that and quality and these
these actually would be you know
continuous values which would be
interesting is it will now this is where
you get into all the complexity of
linear modeling cuz you might say well
will you told me these can be between 0
and 5 well now it's a different problem
but if you assume these are sort of both
continuous things you can even so this
this would be it this would be that
would be all of it so the answer your
question that would be that and then
what you get out is you distributions
for both of those and you could see and
again it's hard to interpret those
distributions but getting back to what
you were saying you could go in and say
okay so I have a thing that I know is a
five-star quality item and it's
currently $20 and it's not selling so
you can put this in put that there
you're gonna get a distribution of what
the rate of sales is based on what
you've learned for that particular thing
which is kind of cool and then you could
say what if I made it eighteen how much
more wouldn't sell you could actually
make that eighteen recalculate this and
you're going to get another distribution
of predictions for that or you're gonna
get a point estimate but you can get a
distribution if you want so the stuff
becomes really powerful and that's where
like I said people when people to go on
about interpretability then this is this
is inference right so you talked about
there's prediction in machine learning
and there's distil inference and this is
the inference problem and you can see
what we're doing is we're kind of
reverse engineering reality right we're
really trying to figure out how things
work and we have to use these simple
models
we can this is why you know if you if
you're talking to a statistician and
they're like hi you swine's using a
neural network because you can't make it
model using a neural network that makes
sense to you and me alright so for
certain problems we have to do that like
I don't really know how language works I
don't think language works as a linear
model so we use machine learning to do
that but for these types of things
especially for a Greg Euler business
problems this is kind of logic we want
to use because we wanted to say things
like ok if we wait for actually one of
the big problems we have is we want to
show products more and see if that helps
them sell more it doesn't always work so
you can actually see how does that work
you can actually I've run experiments
where I model these things as more you
can actually model interactions which I
don't wanna get into but you can
multiply two of these things and then
actually tells how they interact with
each other
so if you wanted to see if students buy
a pencil differently because the deluxe
pencil is mean towards students you can
actually put that in your model and
learn that there's really really no
limit to how far you can go with this
stuff but of course as you get more
complicated you run into more problems
and there's more caches to everything
yeah exactly exactly exactly in which
and I don't want to give this but this
actually is another question if you want
to model that in this notation you can
you could do plus there's a great book
called statistical rethinking if you
want to go really deep it's in are
there's a whole Python set up sup and he
really covers this much better than
Africa is really excellent book for
going to details of this stuff price
times quality this is gonna be really
tricky cuz it's gonna don't do this at
home yet read more about it but to
answer your question this would actually
do this so this is gonna learn a
coefficient for these two things times
each other I believe this is correct
right okay thank you so so yeah so this
and this is what you're gonna learn it's
going on a third coefficient which is
the interaction of these two now this is
tricky cuz you're learning how price
affects it how quality affects it and
then the way price and quality work so
maybe you want to get rid of some of
these and just learn this interaction
that's gonna be kind of weird so there's
a lot of different ways you can do this
as loss it gets really complicated and
then this isn't even touch on the true
power of like Bayesian inference because
you can learn even more about how all
these things interact it is no limit to
to this yeah so yeah yeah actually that
gives a good point so at the very least
if it if it hovers around zero you could
say these things aren't related how are
you gonna pick that apart when it's not
zero is not easy you actually the
typical advice is to actually and this
is way beyond the scope of stuff but you
can actually sample since you have these
two distributions you can run the model
backwards and get uncertainty about all
of your estimates but if you want to
know when these when these interactions
appear you really have to sample from
the data that sort of get a feel for how
it's doing it really is hard to just
interpret so for these simple ones you
can do you know for testing purposes
these sort of simple things like this is
actually even more this is more
complicated and you want to do on a test
right is this giving you a lot of
information but in this simple case you
could at least say is reading you know
what and you can you can see which is
more important price quality obviously
from what we've seen it seems a quality
is less important than price seems to be
a big push for people so and this model
would probably learn that example from
enough examples of things that had
different prices and qualities the model
was giving you estimates for these and
my guess would be that this coefficient
would be in general lower magnitude of
an impact than this would that price is
going to have a more strong impact on
the sales oh we are at 10:30 thank you
I have a blog to count basie and I wrote
a book on this stuff so I wrote a
Haskell book thank you so much